we probably should have coordinated this
better shouldn't we yeah I think so have
you since this is a Christmas special a
holiday special have you been a good or
a bad boy Michael this year well that's
interesting one of the people in the
book Granville Hicks his autobiography
starts with I was a good boy uh and he
wasn't a very good boy
um on a scale of one to ten
I'm trying to think of what bad things
I've done oh okay there's that okay wait
that's not that was no that was not that
that's all right I would say nine nine
yeah I try to do the right thing
okay what are you you're either is it
gonna be one or zero yeah no I'm
extremely self-critical I push the zero
okay I reach for the zero
well mission accomplished so this this
episode is announcing the release of the
white pill a book you wrote which is
um I've gotten the honor the privilege
the pleasure of being one of the first
people to read it you're the first so
I'm really I don't know if nervous is
the word but you are the first person
who has read it that I am speaking to
about it my first my last my everything
yes you say that to all the girls but
I'll take all the fem Bots all the fun
Bots but yeah it was a truly incredible
book it's basically a story of evil in
the 20th century
and throughout it you reveal a thread
that gives us hope and that's the idea
of the white pill so there's the the
blue pill and the red pill
there's the black pill which is a kind
of deeply cynical
um maybe apathetic just giving up on the
world given that you see behind the
curtain and you given that you don't
like what you see given that there's so
much suffering in the world you give up
that's the black pill and the white pill
I suppose is even though you acknowledge
that there's evil in the world you don't
give up yes so if you're listening to
this and you're a fan of this podcast
you go to whitehillblock.com it'll go to
it white pillbook.com and if you don't
know how to spell we'll probably have a
link that you can click on so for people
who also don't know Michael malice is
not just a troll
not just the hilarious comedic genius
who hosts his own podcast but he is an
incredible brilliant author dear reader
the uh unauthorized autobiography Kim
Jong-il so that's a story of North Korea
the new right to Journey To The Fringe
of American politics that's
the story
of uh the extremes of the United States
uh political movements and then the
anarchist handbook that's talking about
the ideologies the different flavors of
ideologies of anarchism but on top of
that you're now going in going into the
darkest
aspects of the 20th century with the
Soviet Union and the communism with the
white pill